new rock and I decided she he rocks
inside that Sunday wasn't a lot we're
honest about her Saturday Sunday
something Isabel very religious country
a lot going on but we did an incredible
thing I'm going to really fall with
somebody seen before and I was a whole
lot of fun a nice rest days and they say
to jam with the team most of all water
for me and Gary be up in the halls to
wrap that there will be two corporate
most about ownership and leverage taking
her to Texas out there's everything
gotta do it man just help tank and a big
100 yeah no yeah that is all yours to
Orleans oscillatoryness bar like
there you were just sitting at your dad
Oh
although good what were you know oh I
found out we see their cool spots all
feel like they're falling ten o'clock
tonight
we're taking another first show off of
variants that's only what you did
I was at my apartment it was just Sunday
a little something yeah and I was
thinking oh by the way I started to lose
my shade and there was nothing acting on
the game there right is like a holding
penalty hey what's going on and I was
like what are you Playboy Texan issues
like like I was like what is my wife I
didn't take Lane I was like oh like I
agree different with my wife like River
glad I wasn't a yeah yeah those exact
remembered how the killer be like like a
little
I'm usually totally shocked following it
taping something I do mr. Quan is the
kind of thing where I totally forgot
about it yeah am I going to hold it up
going is because the LA office wasn't
like you access so I was like the chosen
one from LA man that's where you would
LA at that one okay
the same what about you Maria battle and
Akala like go through the end the gals
we don't bring in another low or like
damned whatever as you like get a slide
on the glass like you don't Akana
I'd like to fly it isn't so scary
understand some point you are what in
studio in Atlanta and you like 21 times
three gallop in blackboard
yes where do you yeah I will Annalee
and William had abroad
and yet God brings better health for
days now a joke people talk for real
quickens every creatures manaslu with
every Africa as I play yes and if I've
time it's too late yo yeah I like it
major yes I got into this so I told you
ahead of time right I say
that's Olivia yeah Tom we're watching
football with my fiance we had just
gotten engaged like a week before work
just kind of a spur interest got a
couple texts you go to Ghana okay I got
all talked up she's like what you're
leaving me for five days that's not
right now I don't drop out like well
cubetto going that's awesome
nature's like wax I want that t-shirt
nature's whack you have some purple
drank onion for finish if we took family
Mississippi didn't let you out huh
remember high club like my first hike
just drop it I was such an outdoor he
did too
it's like this is the kind of place I
would play in like I like the wood I
love the woods I'm very comfortable I'm
very comfortable in it because of my
childhood like I was super into like
let's play GI Joe and Star Wars and
stuff like I made up the scene when I
was a kid called adventures where like
for my friends would follow me around
and like like this and I would like make
up narratives
we'd have to make a viral video see yeah
see like oh I feel like a ran through
the jungles of G Ghana you're
complaining about you with a fire hose
in there that's a sad [ __ ] like we're in
it was a good episode the other day when
we plumbing out some new interesting
content I listened to the whole thing
Valis what do you think yes sir via me
oh yes great the Jersey that you know
AMAs are good too
that was really good the reddit thing I
think document
all time yeah I think that we post on
Saturday we should have been smarter
about it what the am i but I think it's
gonna go viral about itself
yy-you don't think a lot okay right I
think yeah Russia probably wrong me
wrong it's just not something too
completely intuitive thing I don't want
anyone [ __ ] with me not being around to
really promote it yeah
I like this is awesome
it can be very dangerous the ultimate
thing when we can we have something is
giving me an hour on live wall launches
right that's where I think I can hear
that ramp at the end of the episode the
other day some attention
yeah they got a little [ __ ] about not a
[ __ ] teenybopper at a vlog I'm sort
of realized this is one thing I could do
I would use to any land it was a secure
this progress I don't know like it's
just so makes me so happy to like it
makes me just be happy that I guys like
have a good time well I got something
smell like I'm I feed off positivity
yeah literally what goes for my - like I
want to go in there and play you guys
and Solverson it's like straight-up I
was the main I only went through you I
was only the GI Joes for like six months
mine was merely Star Wars two wrestling
figures said Nintendo like if I think
about my core childhood toys it was Star
Wars figures uh oh this is [ __ ] rad
this mushroom should we eat that who
wants to eat that
how much Gary I would eat it how much
you're not eating and that's what we got
to do thank you I seen it laughs no oh
[Music]
so sometimes you just give it to some
rad ass [ __ ] you know um just kind of
separating myself right now from the
trip they value for jobs I think it's
super important to break your pattern
decisions have given mindset whether
it's being prepaying beings respective
or if it's just enjoying yourself going
surfing for three days with your best
friends in college and think it's
massively employees employed patterns
and I think when we're lucky enough to
be in a place where you love what you're
doing you don't read it today refresh
and just for me it's off not see sense
it's not like oh [ __ ] I'm fried out let
me go somewhere it's pure offenses I'm
happy but this gives me different
perspective to do different things in my
mind and whether it's going away for
three days to like a football camp and
try to be a quarterback or if it's going
to post a Ghana and visiting somebody
you know you guys know I think the
things I do that I'm a little bit more
proud of like quiet it's just my style
don't forgive brag or promote the things
are supposed to do as a good human being
but I'm excited about this kind of
similar three episode series right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway just a for all the entrepreneurs
under this is a little before you have
like more of blog assetbook breaking
patterns on often not just doing it when
you're fried out but if everything's
rolling right now he had a good six
months you caught my content in January
you're going this might be the exact
time to not Husker all 24/7 maybe go to
a sports camp in Korea or or you know go
learn how to cook for a weekend breaking
patterns give you different perspective
I think way too many people think about
things like that is like all I need this
to rest the way you this because
everything so stressful I look at the
worse I think it's just good to love
taste different things which gives you
the idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]